>>JESSE: WELCOME TO TRENTO.
I AM JESSE WATTERS.
JAMES COMEY AND HILLARY
CLINTON, THE PERFECT PAIR.
THAT'S THE SUBJECT TONIGHT OF
WATTERS WORDS.
THE TWO MOST PROMINENT
OPPONENTS TRUMP HAS VANQUISHED,
AND OF THEIR LOSSES IN THE
EXACT SAME WAY AND FOR THE
EXACT SAME REASONS.
WE WILL BREAK IT DOWN IN A
SECOND.
HERE'S THE REAL REASON THIS
MATTER TO YOU.
LOSING TO DONALD TRUMP HAS
BECOME A COTTAGE INDUSTRY IN
AMERICA.
CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS ARE NOW
TRAFFICKING IN THEIR DEFEATS
FOR FINANCIAL, PSYCHOLOGICAL
AND REPUTATIONAL REASONS.
WE WANT YOU TO IDENTIFY THESE
PEOPLE AND THEIR TRUE
MOTIVATIONS BEFORE DRINKING THE
KOOL-AID.
SO LET'S BEGIN.
COMEY AND HILLARY FIRED AND
DEFEATED BY DONALD TRUMP.
BOTH WRITE BOOKS AND A PIECE OF
THE ACTION ON THE SALES SIDE.
THEY BOTH GO ON NATIONAL
MAINSTREAM MEDIA TOURS, FREE
PROMOTION FACILITATED BY
FRIENDLY QUESTIONS AND LARGELY
IGNORING COUNTRIES FOR THEIR
NARRATIVE IS CHALLENGED.A
CRITICAL COMPONENT IS
REPUTATION REHAB.
GETTING THEIR STORY OUT THERE.
THEIR STORES ARE THE SAME.
THEY ARE NOT REALLY THE LOSERS.
THEY ARE VICTIMS.
VICTIMS OF UNETHICAL TRUMP
CHEATED THEM OUT OF THEIR
RIGHTFUL TITLES.
BOTH COMEY AND HILLARY SHARE IN
THE SAME DELUSION.
THEY ARE INCAPABLE OF SEEING
THE OTHER SIDE'S VIEWPOINT AND
UNABLE TO ADMIT THEIR OWN
FAULT.
IT'S TOO PAINFUL FOR THEM.
COMEY STILL CAN'T SEE WHY TRUMP
FIRED HIM BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT
DIDN'T TRUST HIM AND THOUGHT HE
WAS INCOMPETENT.
AND HILLARY, SO CAN'T SEE WHY
SHE LOST BECAUSE TRUMP WAS A
BETTER CAMPAIGNER AND VOTERS
DISLIKE HER.
AND BECAUSE THEY ARE SO
SELF-RIGHTEOUS THEY MAKE
EXCUSES.
THE RUSSIANS, OBSTRUCTIONS,
COLLUSION
COLLUSION, THE LIST GOES ON AND
ON.
>> THE INVESTIGATION THEY
CONDUCTED ENDED IN JULY BUT IT
WAS OVER AND THAT
WAS OVER AND THATIT WAS
REIGNITED .
COMEY WAS MORE THAN HAPPY TO
TALK ABOUT MY EMAILS.
YOU HAD CITIZENS UNITED COME TO
ITS FULL FUSION
ITS FULL FUSION.
IF YOU LOOK AT FACEBOOK, THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE NEWS ITEMS
POSTED WERE FAKE.
>>JESSE: THE CONSTANT REWRITING
OF HISTORY IS AN OBSESSION WITH
DONALD TRUMP.
PSYCHOLOGICALLY, THE INABILITY
TO RECONCILE THEIR LOSS WITH
THE TRUTH.
THIS IS WHY COMEY WROTE CREEPY
PASSAGES ABOUT TRUMP'S SKIN AND
HANDS AND WHY HILLARY WON'T
EXIT THE STAGE GRACEFULLY.
COMEY AND HILLARY TRULY BELIEVE
TRUMP IS OBSESSED WITH THEM
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
>> HE'S TWEETED AND HE PROBABLY
50 TIMES.
I'VE BEEN GONE FOR A YEAR, I'M
LIKE A BREAK A PEAK CAN'T GET
OVER.
>>JESSE: THE LAST THING THAT
TIES COMEY AND HILLARY
TOGETHER, POTENTIAL CRIMINAL
ACTS.WE WILL DISCUSS THAT
LATER TONIGHT.
HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE, THERE
IS A MOUNTAIN OF EVIDENCE COMEY
AND HILLARY COMMITTED CRIMES
BUT NO EVIDENCE SO FAR OF TRUMP